tell us what animal is this is a spider
monkey his name is Mambo and Conan you
actually have a bowl of food over there
where's my food I don't want anyone else
touch that he might actually think
differently if you pull out the monkey
food there once he gets a little bit
comfortable here you might reach over
but I want to I'm gonna see if I can get
him over here this is what's his name
his name is Mambo mom I want you to take
a look at his arms and legs and this
huge tail that he has wrapped around my
neck these guys live in South America
they're highly arboreal that means they
live up in the trees and they almost
never come down to the ground to walk it
you just keep feeding him come here oh
yeah he's oh yeah tail but he might
actually climb up on you
Conan if you you gonna let him do that
is that yeah that's totally fine
okay amazing animal you just help that
put food come here look pal he looked at
my hair and he went why does he people
make that way
he pretty much look everywhere except
where the food was but yeah these guys
live up in the trees
they use this tail as a fifth limb Wow
you can see they hold on to it it's just
like Anna look at the reach look at the
length the reach of this amazing
incredible his art his arms are like
proportionately to his body that's why
they call them spider monkeys because
they have such long limbs but you know
these guys like many species that live
in South America and tropical forests
are on the decline because of habitat
destruction right that's why you know I
wanted to bring him on in particularly
because he's so amazing and if we don't
do our job to protect them this is why
that's like to feed my kids in the
morning I'm serious this is exactly what
it's like I feed them one raisin at a
time he likes it takes six hours and
their limbs are just like this there we
go Wow okay he is amazing I love this
guy and I just let him have the whole
bull or is that bad you can let him have
the whole ball put the whole ball you
know he's not gonna complain about it oh
he doesn't want the whole bowl no you
said no what's happening now if you he's
not always noticing the crowd
yeah he's never what he's checking
everybody out he's just looked at the
crowd he's like I like this crowd I
don't you want to come on back up come
on okay all right we should probably
keep moving cuz we have a lot of animals
together but I love what's his name
again [ __ ] Mambo Mambo he just touched
my case in a very sensual way
Kayle just taking my whitey to step in
and okay hello hello this is just an
audience member taking there we go all
right here you have a both oh my God
look at that the pellets here you can
start feeding okay right African crown
crane okay follow you come up front here
throw the food down that's what I would
look like if I was a crane there you go
some of our hair cut we do its exactly
have the same long limbs I got him I got
him right here if you speed look at this
come to me come to me puts them on the
table here she might hop up I think
she'll come up on the table okay whoa
so a beautiful bird from Africa hence
the name African crowned crane they've
got that big feathers efforts that
really hurts you but I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna do it cuz I think it's more
convenient for you oh that's what it was
like on Halloween the other night I
would hold that these birds right there
right there problem these guys are a
perfect example of how dinosaurs
actually evolved into birds when you
look at like a Robin it's hard to see
that but when you see an atom like a
crane with those big scaly legs and
those long necks it's kind of like a
velociraptor I'll get it for ya right
here see your friends oh okay okay
taking some flesh all right well we're
gonna have to move on ray but I
absolutely love this animal we gonna
bring her back this way okay and this is
how you lead her everywhere is this how
you get her through Los Angeles we just
reading that yeah belong all right come
on sweetie this way hey there we go
and eat you want to come this way this
way Oh
yeah we want to throw the food this way
so that I want to get like crew member a
drinking man
you